this is an inspirational true story of
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him who was sent to the whole of
mankind as a mercy Allah says in the
Quran I have sent you
Oh prophet only as a mercy for the whole
world this story testifies to his
credibility with the people even before
being summoned as a mighty messenger
from the Almighty now in the years
before the revelation the Claridge
decided to rebuild a cover the Kaaba for
those that don't know was the first
house of worship built by Abraham and
his son Ishmael for the worship of the
One God a note to remember also is that
Muslims don't worship the Kaaba nor do
we worship the blackstone Muslims
worship only God alone no partners no
children no parents no Saints no man nor
woman but only the Creator do we worship
and not his creation as many people do
but just God Almighty alone now when it
came to rebuilding the foundation the
nobles of Quraysh began to argue which
could have erupted the tribal conflict
and violence over whom should have the
honor of setting the black stone in the
proper place they finally agreed that
the next man who entered the sanctuary
should arbitrate the matter by his
mid-thirties Muhammad had earned the
title of enemy the trustworthy for his
reputation is one of the most honest and
upright men in Mecca the Prophet was
distinguished among his people for his
modesty virtuous behavior for his
gracious manners he proved himself to be
the ideal of manhood and to possess a
spotless character he was the most
obliging to his fellow citizens the most
honest and talk in the mildest and
temper
he was the most gentle hearted chaste
and hospitable he always impressed
people by his piety inspiring
expressions he was the most truthful and
the best to keep his word promise and
covenant his fellow citizens gave him
the title of LME the trustworthy now
surprisingly when Muhammad entered the
premises the Meccan chiefs were happy to
let unliving arbitrate the matter after
listening to all sides of the debate
Muhammad decided that the stone should
be placed on a cloak and raised by all
once it was lifted to the correct level
he would position it himself they agreed
with his decision and supported him as
he set the stone in its appropriate
place let us follow in the footsteps of
an limine the trustworthy and be
trustworthy ourselves let us follow in
the footsteps of prophet muhammad peace
be upon him and be kind merciful giving
and charitable morally upright and of
noble character obliging to our
neighbors and fellow citizens let us
follow in the footsteps of the greatest
men who ever walked this earth the
message is that God Almighty sent like
Abraham Moses Jesus and Mohammed peace
be upon them all who all called people
to worship the Creator alone and not his
creation take a moment now and fulfill
one of those qualities and that's of
giving towards the Dawa something all
these great Giants did and call people
to do help us reach our yearly goal for
Ramadan help be part of sharing the
truth support the detail